I didn't always have a skin that I felt
confident in
that's why I never sleep my skincare
[Music]
even if that means doing my skincare in
the middle of nowhere on a field or
doing it falling asleep after a night
shift and this is my three-step skincare
routine it's focused on keeping the skin
acne free healthy and to minimize
getting wrinkles with age as some of you
might know I'm a fourth year medical
student and I'm presenting this video as
part of my doctors as teachers
assessment at medical school I had acne
for five years of my life but this
skincare routine that I do is not how I
got rid of my chronic acne for that I
was on Accutane slash I search
retinoline last year first day of
fracture time acid reasoning capsules
and if you'd find it helpful I can do a
separate video about that so skincare
supplements and externally helps the
skin with current skincare markets there
are millions of options you can go for
and I've been a victim of that and spent
hundreds of pounds on those but came to
conclusion that minimalist simple skin
care works best for me as too many
products can irritate the skin that's
why my skincare routine is in three
simple stages cleansing moisturizing
sunscreen in the morning and retinoid in
the evening firstly cleansers they help
remove dirt pollutants makeup that can't
be removed with only water so it's for
the ones that are stuck in your pores
studies found that hydrating cleansers
are helpful in restoring the Skin
Barrier which is important in
inflammatory skin conditions like acne
and eczema that's why I use the CeraVe
hydrating cleanser which is very gentle
so even if you have oily or acne prone
skin drying out the skin with harsh
cleanses will only make it worse by
impairing that Skin Barrier to design
evolve and wash away both oil and
water-based diet I double cleanse with
both oil and water-based cleansers first
I use this oat cleansing balm by the
inkyles this gets rid of any oil-based
debris on my skin like sunscreen or
makeup then to remove any sweats or
bacteria or dead skin cells I use this
CeraVe hydrating cleanser which is a
water-based product of course first I
wash my hands then here is me struggling
to squeeze out the last bits of the oak
cleansing Bowl this is how it looks like
then I gently rub it in in circular
motions for a minute after I rinse the
oil-based cleanser off my face then I go
in with the hydrating cleanser
especially focusing on where I'm prone
to getting acne on my face so for me
it's my jawline and cheeks again I try
not to rush it and do it thoroughly for
about a minute one downside of this so
rehydrating cleanser is that as you can
see it's not that foamy double cleansing
is optional using only water-based
cleanser is usually good enough to clean
the skin but I love how soft and smooth
my skin feels after using an oil-based
cleanser as well second step is
moisturizing for that I use this La
Roche
post per se per se
Duo I've been using this for five years
of my life after my dermatologist
recommend it to me for my acne it helps
prevent those fun people blemishes and
it would even calm down my sister
cackney when I used to get those I
really do see a difference in my skin
when I use this and the moment I stop
using it I noticed some little pimples
coming back one downside of this is that
it's not that great at hydrating the
Skin So if it's winter time or if I feel
dry after using this then I use this
peptide moisturizer by the inky list on
top I apply the moisturizer on my
eyebrows as well because I get dry and
Flaky eyebrow skin there then for better
absorption into my skin I slap myself on
the face this gives my skin a nice
plumpness and leaves me hydrated one
very common mistake that is done which I
was doing as well until one of the
doctors I was working with corrected me
is that putting moisturizer onto dry
skin after washing my face I don't towel
dry my face completely so I put
moisturizer when my face is still damp
you don't need to have literally water
dripping down from your face but it
should still be wet so the moisturizer
locks that water in your skin if it's
daytime then the third step is sunscreen
you must be hearing everyone preaching
about sunscreen everywhere but it is for
a good reason a month ago I had my
Dermatology placement at medical school
and there were a lot of skin cancers due
to sun damage obviously just because you
don't use sunscreen doesn't mean you're
going to get skin cancer but over 80
percent of skin cancers are caused by
overexposure to UV radiation so it
increases your risk a lot this picture
went viral on the internet this lady put
sunscreen on her face but not on her
neck and you can see an obvious
difference there it shows how sunscreen
minimizes the signs of skin aging like
wrinkles spotting loss of elasticity in
the skin sunscreen also helps with
fading of acne scars which I have some
because of my acne history like you can
see here
and especially on this side it's more
that's why I see sunscreen as an
investment to My Future Self yes it can
feel sticky oily it is effort to put it
on but for a healthy and pressy aging
skin it's worth it plus I found a
sunscreen that feels good on my skin it
doesn't leave a white cast it gives you
a nice glow it's not sticky it is this
fondy Sands SPF 50. I put sunscreen on
my face neck and on tops of my ears
which is the most easily forgotten area
and I put the rest on my hands sunscreen
ideally should be reapplied every two to
three hours but honestly sometimes I
forget but I'm trying to get better at
it I bought another one of these just to
keep it in my bag so I can red blood
during the day when I'm outside as well
if it's night time then the third step
is retinoid it is one of the most
researched ingredients in the skincare
world and it has great evidence for its
benefits first benefits and the main
reason I'm using it for its anti-aging
effects I'm in my early 20s and the
American Academy of Dermatology
recommend starting in your 20s so you
don't need to to wait until you see
signs of aging like wrinkles because
retinoid is preventative it's kind of
like sunscreen with long-term use it's
an investment that you see the benefits
of as you age second benefit is it helps
with acne scars and uneven pigmentation
of the skin and third benefit is it
minimizes acne breakouts considering my
acne history retinoid has great benefits
for me and it's essentially in my
skincare while all of these benefits
come with some side effects especially
in the first few months of starting
using retinoids it can cause dry skin
peeling but that helps produce new skin
cells which is part of the reason why it
helps with acne scars and you get a
smoother skin it can make your skin
sensitive red and if you're not careful
you can even burn your skin like I did
before I burnt my face so this side
isn't too bad so it's crucial to build
that tolerance to minimize those side
effects I first started using a weaker
form of retinoid called retinol it is
this beauty pie super retinol with
hyaluronic acid which makes it very
gentle after a few months I moved up to
a stronger form of retinoid called
tretinoin there are different strengths
you can go for currently I'm at 0.05
strength of acne lines with tretinoin
where I went wrong before which caused
me to have those little burns on my skin
was that I wasn't patient enough to
increase this strength first start using
only a pea-sized amount for the whole
face and only once or twice a week then
slowly do it every other night then
every night so to safely integrate
retinoid into your skincare this whole
process should be over a few months so
very slowly male versus female skincare
I've been asked to do a skincare routine
that is suitable for both males and
females even though in medical school
we're taught about hormonal differences
between male and female when it comes to
Skin Care those gender specific products
are mostly part of the marketing game so
it's there for your money so the
products that are in my skincare routine
are suitable for all genders so it's
actually pretty simple three-step
skincare care routine I hope you found
it helpful consider subscribing and I'll
see in the next one
[Music]